hey i'm vanessa lachey and i am here to
play a game of true love
do you believe in true love i do
first question
relationship advice wow that is a loaded
question who am i to know what to tell
you but what's worked for me and my
husband we've been together for 15 years
and we've been married for 10. i think
that the best thing for us is
communication i know it sounds cliche
but to break it down a little deeper
don't assume the other person knows even
if you've been together for 15 years
they don't know what you're thinking
they might assume what you're thinking
but if you want to be clear and you want
to be honest with yourself just
communicate in a loving way turn towards
your partner and and talk to them and i
think that that will resolve a ton of
misunderstandings and hopefully fights
and lead to more cuddles and good times
do you believe in love at first sight i
don't
and that sounds crazy i don't want to
say i'm not a hopeless romantic
the reason i don't is because i think
that love at first sight is basing it
strictly on your looks coincidentally my
husband and i did a show for netflix
called love is blind where people
actually fall in love by getting to know
the person and then they see them i do
think that looks play a factor into a
relationship i mean at the end of the
day things about that person have to
attract you but what i found is when i
get to know someone they become more
beautiful their eyes sparkle a little
more their smile and even like the
quirkiness with their smile is something
that i love and you can have the most
handsome or beautiful person and they're
just such
that you actually think that they don't
look great so
i don't believe in love at first sight
but i do believe in feelings and tingles
and instinct follow your instinct next
question favorite rom-com love actually
hands down yeah i'm sorry i'm saying i'm
sorry because it sounds so cliche but
it's mine in my husband's favorite
holiday movie probably our favorite
movie and in fact when we got married
once we were husband and wife and they
said i pronounce you husband wife you
can kiss the bride and we walked off as
mr and miss lachey
to the song that they did in the movie
the beatles song so
that's how much we loved the movie it
has all the things there you go
any changes to love is blind season two
honestly the biggest change is for me
and nick so for season one when you were
watching love is blind you only saw us i
think it was like six moments but we
were there the entire
was eight weeks we prepped we were with
them every day we saw them before they
went in the pods after the pots we
weren't there at night time when they
went in pods but we were there for a lot
of the narrowing down we were there for
proposals we were hiding in the back
rooms before they went in after they
came out we were there for all of it
obviously when they edited it and got it
together for season two they're like
really we just used you guys for the
intro when they get to their destination
and then we were there for all the
weddings we got to see all the weddings
i got to talk to lauren before she
walked down the aisle with cameron i got
to talk to amber before she walked down
the aisle with barnett and nick talked
to barnett and nick talked to cameron
which is why when we shot the reunion i
literally was brought to tears in some
of the questions because i felt like i
really truly knew these people's love
story season two i was looking at a
paper with their name and their photo
and so i didn't get to really know their
story
as much and that for that i'm bummed out
about but i do know that they brought it
that's just my humble opinion on drew
love i'm vanessa lachey and i co-host
love is blind on netflix with my husband
nick lachey and keep an eye out for
season two
and three
[Music]
you